today on the matt welsh show the navy
puts out a new instructional video
teaching sailors and other military
members how to use and respect a
person's preferred pronouns we have the
actual instructional video which we will
play for you today because you have to
see it for yourself to believe it also
republicans sell out on gun control but
did they actually sell out or are they
simply doing
exactly what we expect them to do and
what they've always done we'll talk
about that and a mother raises a quarter
of a million dollars based on a horrific
story of her son being bullied the only
problem is that the story doesn't seem
to be true at what point will people
stop falling for these kinds of scams in
our daily cancellation the left is
justifying child drag shows by comparing
them to 90s cross-dressing comedies like
mrs doubtfire but this argument actually
undermines and destroys their own
premise i'll explain why all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
you know in the past public schools were
simply neglecting foundational subjects
like math english science and history
many looked the other way now we see
woke teachers proudly bragging on social
media about pushing radical sometimes
sexually charged propaganda on kids as
young as five years old there are even
reports of teachers secretly hosting
drag shows for students without the
consent of parents all with the blessing
of unions and some members of congress
as well so if you want a real education
for your child you need freedom project
academy they have perfected live online
learning for more than a decade freedom
project academy is built on
judeo-christian values and classical
curriculum they're dedicated to
providing mastery of subject matter not
leftist propaganda all you got to do is
go to
freedomforschool.com that's
freedomforschool.com to request your
free information packet today and you
got to do that because think about this
what is a college degree worth if the
average public school graduate can only
read and write at a 7th grade level go
to freedomforschool.com that's
freedomforschool.com
and get your child enrolled at freedom
project academy before spots fill up
that's freedomforschool.com
freedomforschool.comfreedomforschool.com
yesterday we talked about the fact that
we live in a theocracy not a christian
theocracy of course we aren't that
fortunate but a theocracy which governs
according to the leftist religion now i
firmly believe
that leftism is the modern equivalent of
a religion and uh that much of what it
does and how its adherents behave
can best be understood through the lens
of religion though i also do worry that
i'm insulting religion by calling
leftism a religion after all most
religions are much more impressive uh
intellectually richer more more
systematically coherent
have far greater and more meaningful
substance than leftism does perhaps it's
just better to call leftism an ideology
or a political theory and leave it at
that
but that i think doesn't quite capture
uh what this thing is in its fullness it
doesn't account for the zeal of its
adherents or its dogmatic nature or
the faith required to believe anything
that it preaches what makes this a
religion ultimately is that it has its
own high priests its own sacraments its
own holy days its own spiritual
convictions its own tenets and
dogmas its own canon its own catechism
it hunts for heretics and punishes
blasphemers it exiles its apostates and
calls for complete submission to its
doctrines
it has its own higher power its own god
which is the self the individual ego uh
it may be a flimsier weirder less
intellectually rigorous
shallower version of religion but it is
a religion all the same and that's how
we can
begin to make sense of this as the
washington free beacon first reported
quote the navy is training its members
to create a safe space by using proper
gender pronouns in a new instructional
video modeled after a children's show
the official training video is meant to
emphasize quote the importance of using
correct pronouns as well as polite
etiquette when you may not be sure of
somebody's pronouns according to the
navy which late last month published a
video online the defense visual
information distribution service touts
the video as an official u.s navy video
posted by air force staff sergeant john
vannucci
now if you go to the defense visual
information distribution service website
it will connect you over to the naval
sea systems command website where you
can find a longer explanation for this
pronoun video in an article titled
empowering a diverse workforce naval sea
systems command inclusion and engagement
projects take shape we're told the
following quote
the diversity team is creating a video
series called nav speaks to educate and
empower employees to reach their full
potential the program started off as a
ted talks kind of video platform for the
navsea community to connect employees to
opportunities the video platform bridges
employees to programs resources and
opportunities for leadership development
and career advancement by highlighting
diverse voices and perspectives nav
speaks educates and empowers future
leaders who will represent the community
they serve nav speaks will transition to
the office of engagement diversity and
inclusion at the end of the fiscal year
so we go back now to the washington free
beacon report with a little more added
context it says the video is the latest
bid by the military to foster a more
sensitive environment for its members
and staff the army mandates similar
gender identity training and trains
officers on when to offer subordinates
gender transition surgery according to
the washington free beacon report in
march these programs are part of a
larger push by the button administration
to make the military more welcoming to
transgender individuals
now
with all that in mind it's time to
actually watch the video and i'm sure
you didn't think that you'd escape this
segment without being subjected to the
video itself you know me better than
that by now
and so here it is this is the actual
instructional video produced by and for
the navy
while other countries are training their
military members on how to more
effectively brutalize and kill the enemy
we're training ours
with this
hi my name is johnny and i use he him
pronouns hi and i am kanji and i use chi
her pronouns and we're here to talk
about pronouns
what is a pronoun a pronoun is how we
identify ourselves apart from our name
and it's also how people refer to us in
conversations using the right pronouns
is a really simple way to affirm
someone's identity it is a signal of
acceptance and respect if it's a signal
of acceptance and respect how do we go
about creating a safe space for
everybody
that's a good question a really good way
to do that is to use inclusive language
instead of saying something like hey
guys you can say hey everyone or hate
team
yeah and now that you say that another
way that we could show that we're allies
and that we accept
everybody is to maybe include our
pronouns in our emails or like we just
did introduce ourselves using our
pronouns but what would i do if i
uh misgender someone
i think the first thing to recognize is
that it's not the end of the world you
correct yourself and move on or you
accept the correction and move on the
most important thing i can tell you is
do not put the burden of making you feel
good about your mistake on the person
that you just misgendered oh thank you
for telling me that
thank you for telling us that
she says that we must not put any burden
on the person that we just misgendered
but that person could put all kinds of
burdens on us in fact we are saddled
with the burden of having to adopt and
affirm that individual's misconceptions
about reality we must participate in
their game of charades whether we're in
the mood for a game or not
if that person is playing dress-up and
make-believe the burden is on us
to abide by the rules of their game we
can't simply exist and mind our own
business and live the way we like we
must live how that other person wants us
to live and think the way they want us
to think and say the things they want us
to say this is all the name of creating
a safe space for that person now if we
would like a safe space of our own a
safe space from this kind of lunacy
altogether we're out of luck
that's what we've learned in this navy
instructional video so far what we
haven't learned though is anything that
has anything to do with
being in the navy
maybe eventually we'll get around to
that let's keep watching
yeah and another tip uh for you to
remember their uh
pronoun next time it's in your mind kind
of go through a progression of three
good things about the person using their
pronouns so let's say the person
chooses to use day
then you will in your mind go
they have a nice shirt
they have a nice smile they are really
smart so that kind of sticks in your
brain that is so helpful
no it would be more like
they have blue hair
they are delusional
they are pushy and annoying
they can kiss my ass
i'm not playing this game am i doing
that right see that's the problem with
this trick it assumes that there's
anything nice to say about the kind of
person who prefers the pronoun they
now you've got me searching for the one
positive needle in this haystack of
unpleasant personality traits and the
whole thing's gotten a lot more
complicated
and what you still haven't done with
this video is explain why i should care
about anybody's preferred pronouns in
the first place why is this my problem
give me one good reason why i should
give a damn
let's see what you got
i want to know what would i do if i want
to know someone's gender identity or
pronouns the most important thing is
do not pressure anybody into giving you
their pronouns some people may be going
through the process of discovery and
they are not ready yet to tell you what
their pronouns are and that's okay so i
should just lead with my pronouns and
they may follow or not and if they don't
then i can just continue to use
gender-neutral language yes exactly just
to share something with you that
happened
the other day at akuka i was at we were
talking about pronouns and somebody was
disagreeing with
how different people
see themselves as different pronouns and
the argument was if you look like a
female then it's chi her because that's
what's normal and if you make me call
you something else then you're
infringing on my rights and i i was
really taken aback by the comment and i
really wasn't sure
how to respond and the only thing i
could really think quickly to say was
[Music]
it's not about you at all
and
it's mostly and ultimately about respect
it is about respect
what kind of cookout in hell are you
attending
where people stand around talking about
pronouns
there's no way these people even eat
meat so what are they grilling imagine
finding yourself at a barbecue where
they've got nothing but zucchini and
tofu burgers on the grill and everyone
begins every conversation by giving
their pronouns
but this lady's telling it sounds like
there was maybe one normal person who
wandered into this zoo and made the very
good point that females are she her and
it's an infringement on his free speech
rights to try and force him to call a
female anything other than that
the lady in the video sitting next to
her hen pecked patsy whose only role is
to just agree with everything she says
apparently is uh she says that she was
shocked to encounter someone who feels
this way
which that doesn't surprise me after we
filmed what is a woman of course we
encountered many people like this who
are just shocked they can't believe that
anyone exists who would disagree
with these ideas that they invented 15
seconds ago
and she insists that it's not about you
and and really this is just a matter of
respect
but see that's the problem
if you're telling me
what i have to say
and what i have to affirm
and the beliefs that i have to pretend
that i hold
then how is it not about me
no it's definitely about me
okay it is i mean i'm the one we're
talking about right
now you see it goes the other way around
if you have preferred pronouns that
differ from your biological identity
and i decline to use them
and we are talking about my own actions
here so this is we're talking about me
not you
that decision on my part
is not about you
it's not an attack on you personally
anymore that i'm attacking you
personally when i say that two plus two
equals four or that the sun is hot or
that the ocean is made of water i am
simply choosing to live in reality
that's all
you might prefer that i live somewhere
else but that's not my problem
okay i am no more under an obligation
to live in your fantasy land because you
want me to
than i am to live you know in cincinnati
ohio because you want me do you might as
well tell me i want you to pick up and
move and move to cincinnati why should i
because i want you to live there that's
why i want you to live
what
it's not about you
i want you to live there how's it not
about me that you're talking about where
i live
i want to live in realities where i want
to live
and you should respect my desire to
exist in reality and to use words that
make sense and to abide by the rules of
proper grammar
i demand that you respect that
i'm the one demanding respect
and if you won't
then i am under under no obligation to
respect your lack of respect for me and
for reality
see this is how we have to start framing
this because it's true
when you go around talking about your
preferred pronouns that is a lack of
respect for everybody else telling me
your preferred pronouns is a lack of
respect for you are disrespecting me
by trying to impose this on me
but i feel like we've strayed from the
point here
right the real the real question is
why any of this is being discussed in an
instruction video for the navy
will preferred pronouns make the
military more ready more able more
lethal
more prepared to devastate and destroy
our enemies
is there some sort of tactical advantage
to having service members who possess a
deep knowledge of non-binary gender
identities no of course not
of course there is
but we live in a left-wing theocracy
and these are its doctrines
and they always always come first
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
many of us spend more time every day in
our office chair than in our cars or on
our beds that's why it's so important to
invest in the right chair to spend those
hours with the right level of support
and comfort to get the most productivity
out of your day xchair has made my time
at my desk not only more productive but
it's honestly my favorite place to sit
for any reason not only does xchair's
patented dynamic variable lumbar or dvl
offer the ultimate customized support
but my ex chair can even give me a
massage or heat up or cool down and do
all of that and now thanks dex chair's
new fs 360 armrests i can even adjust my
armrest to the perfect position for me
all these unique x-chair features help
the hours at my desk fly by in complete
comfort that's why i love my ex chair so
go to
xchairwalsh.com now that's the letter x
chair
walsh.com or call one eight four four
four x chair for a hundred dollars off
your order x chair has a 30 day
guarantee of complete support and
comfort and you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month ex
chairwalsh.com
we start with this from the daily wired
says more than a dozen republicans
joined a largely democrat effort to
advance a gun control bill in the senate
on tuesday night
notable republican senators including
senators john cornyn lindsey graham and
mitch mcconnell helped democrats pass a
procedural vote 64-34 a mere two hours
after the text of the bill circulated uh
the bill could be passed later this week
by the senate and then move on to the
house where it's expected to pass the
bill would then go to president biden's
desk notably the 80 page legislation
includes language on highly
controversial so-called red flag laws
so they had in two hours they had read
you know the entire 80 page legislation
and thought about it deeply and decided
to go ahead and move forward according
to fox news the bill provides grants for
states that implement their own red flag
laws and offers additional funding for
both school safety measures and mental
health services
cornyn though claimed on the senate
floor tuesday that the bill would not
create a national red flag law adding
that states could receive a the funding
regardless of whether they enact such a
program
quote the measure also creates penalties
for straw purchases of firearms requires
more gun sellers to register as
federally licensed firearm dealers and
closes the so-called boyfriend loophole
by prohibiting gun access for people
convicted of domestic abuse against an
intimate partner
um
gun owners of america said in a press
release sent to the daily wire that the
legislation would encourage backdoor
universal background checks by
redefining many private sellers as gun
dealers financially incentivizing states
to enact unconstitutional red flag laws
and would allow for so-called enhanced
background checks which are arbitrary
delays and transferring firearms to
adults not yet 21 years old
so that's the basics of the bill as far
as anyone knows against 80 pages and
they
voted to move forward with the
legislation after just two hours of the
text being made available and being
circulated uh the full list of the 14
republicans who voted on the bill
there's no surprises here at all uh
john cornyn mitch mcconnell lindsey
graham bill cassidy roy blunt richard
burr
mitt romney rob portman like i said no
surprises uh shelly moore capito joni
ernst lisa murkowski todd young
and uh tom tillis are the and susan
collins of course how could i forget
i'll decide the usual suspects decided
to vote for this bill
and um
you know the
the problem with the bill are numerous
we've talked about most of the problems
already starting with the fact that that
none of these
measures
would have done anything to prevent what
happened in uvalde texas or what
happened in buffalo
and we know that because
a number of these measures were already
on the books including the red flag logs
laws in new york and that shooting still
happened
so that's the first issue and the second
issue and it goes beyond this too but
you know we don't really need to get
beyond the red flag laws
and the ways that these are going to be
used and you know some people are saying
the red flag laws are going to be abused
or misused
so as to disarm and punish the
ideological opponents of the regime
but i wouldn't call that a misuse or an
abuse that's actually
what the is intended that's that is in
fact the proper use of these red flag
laws that's that's why they're being put
in place
is precisely for that reason
um to give the regime the ability to
disarm whoever they want
because all i have to say is that uh
there's a red flag on it that person
might be dangerous
remember it's not that um they're saying
that if you're convicted of a violent
crime we're going to take your guns away
that's already the case
that law is already on the books
in like 15 different forms
okay if you're a violent criminal
uh for one thing you're going to prison
or you should be anyway unless you're
unless you're a violent violent criminal
in like los angeles or san francisco um
but ideally you go to prison we don't
have to worry about you
committing acts of violence against the
public at that point
so we're not talking about that what
we're talking about is someone who has
not been convicted of any violent crime
by which the state declares is a is a
potential threat to commit violence in
the future
and that is um
to put up very mildly extremely
subjective
and it's up to that we have to trust
that the state
will have some sort of
insight into this
maybe they have those uh what was it in
minority report they had those
those uh psychics that they kept in a
giant vat of like petroleum jelly with
their brains hooked is it is that am i
making this up or was that in minority
report that was minority report okay
thanks that's what i never understood
about that movie is that it's in the
future and they've got all this crazy
technology
and you think oh they have technology to
read the future and they don't they just
have psychics in a vat of petroleum
jelly anyway so is that what it's going
to be do they have the psychics in the
petroleum jelly that they can you know
and then the psychics will tell them if
someone's i don't think so
it's up to the state to determine who
they think is going to be violent in the
future
and um what we we don't need to
speculate about this
the ruling regime what do they consider
the red flags to be
we already know
if you're on the right then
automatically you're a suspected
terrorist
uh if you're
if you're a in the in the pta if you're
if you're a parent at a school board
meeting
objecting to anything that the school
board is doing
you're a suspected domestic terrorist
that's a red flag take the guns away
if you don't if you watch that
navy instruction video and didn't agree
with everything you saw in it
then that's a red flag and by the way
that's not just that you you might
commit violence in the future you are
committing violence right now if you
misgender someone that is an act of
violence
that's uh genocidal that's that's
murderous
so that's how these laws are going to be
used
republicans support it anyway
should we be surprised by that well of
course not
and um if you are surprised by it then i
think
and the people who are surprised by
still have not quite
come to understand
that these people these republicans
the reason why they're betraying you
is yeah we could say that they're
cowards and that they're squishes and
all of that stuff spineless
that's not exactly it actually
i mean they are cowards but that's not
really the problem
or at least the problem goes beyond that
the real problem is that they don't
believe
what you believe
okay so it's not as though they believe
firmly in gun rights but then they were
just
scared
right and they were and they were they
collapsed under the pressure and decided
to support this bill anyway
that's not it
they don't care about gun rights they
don't care about any of this stuff they
don't care about any of the things you
care about they don't believe what you
believe
they believe what
the supposed opposition believes
they agree with the democrats on almost
everything
and even the the disagreements they do
have they don't really care that much
about them
this is the fundamental problem with
conservative leadership so-called
conservative leadership
pretty much everywhere in every
institution in government
in media
a lot of the conservatives who have put
them themselves into positions of being
sort of spokesmen and leaders in media
it's true of them in the churches
in all of these areas we we often chalk
it up to cowardice and that's a big part
of it i mean i wrote a book called
church of cowards
but even beyond that these
these people they don't actually believe
this stuff
that's the first problem
and that explains
what they did now for a a simpler um
though far more tragic case of
cowardice
we go to uvalde texas um
and the first thing that we have to
mention down in uvalde and i just saw
this headline pop up let me see if i can
find it again
so i just saw before i went on there i
saw this headline pop up this is
breaking911 on twitter it says rob
elementary the texas school where 19
children and two teachers were killed in
a mass shooting
will be demolished according to the
uvalde mayor so they're going to
demolish the school
now it's very interesting because uvalde
is the site of
a massacre
right
a horrific crime
and it also is where this law
enforcement scandal and cover-up
revolves around
and they're going to demolish it
which seems an awful lot like getting
rid of the evidence to me
this is from the texas tribune and it's
worth going to texas tribune to read the
latest on this story and it's it is a
story that just it really does get worse
every single day
and you get to a point you think well
this it can't get worse than this this
is as bad as it could possibly get and
then more revelations it gets even worse
so it's worth going to texas tribune to
see uh they've been following the story
and reporting on it
but i'll read a little bit from this
this is the the latest as of uh
yesterday afternoon
says the officers in the hallway of rob
elementary wanted to get inside
classrooms 111 and 112 immediately one
officer's daughter was inside another
officer had gotten a call from his wife
a teacher who told him she was bleeding
to death
two closed doors on a wall stood between
them and an 18 year old with an ar-15
who had opened fire on children and
teachers inside the connected classrooms
a halogen bar was available that's an
axe-like forcible entry tool uh used by
firefighters to get into rooms like this
ballistic shields were arriving on the
scene so it was plenty of firepower
including at least two rifles some
officers were itching to move
one such officer a special agent at the
texas department of public safety had
arrived around 20 minutes after the
school shooting started he immediately
asked are there kids still in the
classroom
the agent said if there is then we have
to go in
and another officer answered it's
unknown at this time the agent shot back
you all don't know if there's kids in
there he added if there's kids in there
we need to go in
and then the reply came whoever is in
charge will determine that
the inaction appeared too much for the
special agent he noted that there were
still children in other classrooms
within the school who needed to evacuate
well there's kids over here he said so
i'm getting kids out and he went to get
the kids out
this exchange happened
early in the excruciating 77 minutes on
may 24th that started when salvador
ramos
walked through an unlocked door of robb
elementary
and
walked into the classroom and began
shooting
and we're told now that there were that
there were basically four bursts of
shooting from the shooter
and that this continued throughout the
77 minutes while these officers were
outside the room now the san antonio
express news reported that there is no
evidence that officers tried the doors
on rooms 111 and 112. they didn't even
try
to open it this contradicts a key
assertion by the vivaldi school police
chief pete arredondo who told the texas
tribune that officers tried the doors
found them locked and had to wait for a
master key to unlock them
so this aradondo guy has lied i mean has
been doing nothing but lying
from the very beginning
and he claimed they couldn't get into
the door they didn't have a key it turns
out the door was unlocked
they didn't even try to open it
and they also had a tool in case it was
it did turn out to be locked they had a
tool to open it anyway
here's this detail it says another
officer who entered the hallway was
ruben ruiz of the uvalde school district
police force his wife teacher eva
morales had called him on his cell phone
and told him she was bleeding heavily
she says she is shot he told the
officers on the scene
the video from inside the hallway
doesn't capture what ruiz did inside the
school but a dps official told that
tribune that ruiz was soon escorted away
by other officers on the scene
okay so
just to summarize here and like i said
there's plenty more revelations you go
read the whole article
uh
they're they're sitting outside the
classroom for 77 minutes they have
ballistic shields they have um
they have
heavy firepower power they didn't even
try to open the door
which it looks as though now was
unlocked the entire time they could have
just opened it and went right in
and um this scumbag is executing
children this entire time
meanwhile
one of the officers his own wife is
bleeding to death inside the classroom
and we
we hear from other sources that were
there
that he said he wanted to go in they
told him to stand down
he refused and tried to rush in to save
his wife as any husband would and they
stopped him detained him took his gun
away
and and brought him out of
the school
repeating a scene that was very similar
to what was going on outside the school
where there were parents trying to rush
in to save their their uh their kids and
they were being detained i mean
according to reports at least one person
was tased
so these cowards are sitting there and
doing absolutely nothing at all
and the people who want to do something
to save their loved ones are being
physically prevented from doing so so
the physical force is being used against
the husbands and parents who are trying
to save you know their wives and
children from certain death
and keep something else in mind too
because
you know there's this question about and
i think there's still a question we
still don't know for sure
during that 77 minutes while the cowards
were just sitting outside in fear afraid
to move uh we still don't know for sure
how many kids were shot during that time
most of the shooting happened in the
three minutes before cops arrived on the
scene
but we do know that he continued to fire
so there were kids being killed they
were victims being claimed that entire
time
um there were also people that were shot
in the first three minutes and were
bleeding to death like this officer's uh
wife
but then but then there's something else
too that um
along with the you know the the physical
trying to save these kids physically
just the idea of leaving kids
in that classroom
in that situation for over an hour
i mean the unimaginable psychological
and emotional toll that that must take
on these kids and they have to live with
it for the rest of their lives
can you imagine what that was i mean you
can't nobody can
to be a you know an eight-year-old kid
hiding under a desk
inside this classroom for over an hour
while your your friends are bleeding to
death all around you and there's this
crazed gunman just walking around
taunting you that's
i don't think you ever fully recover
there's no way to fully recover from the
psychological trauma there
and my point is that that would be
reason enough
aside from actually saving the lives of
the kids who had not yet been murdered
just saving them from the psychological
emotional trauma is reason enough to go
in there and risk your own life in the
process
so this is this is obviously cowardice
but of a particular kind uh yes they
feared for their safety you know so it's
physical cowardice
but it's also moral cowardice because
that's the one thing that comes comes
out from all the the reports we're
reading now
as there are more and more revelations
every single day
is that everybody was waiting around for
the order
all right we just heard how the one
you know law enforcement officer shows
up he says why aren't we going in oh
we're waiting for the order we're
waiting waiting to be given an order
and then the police chief that soft
puffy pudgy little worthless coward
aradondo
he was there and he was waiting around
for whatever he was waiting for signed
from heaven i don't know
and so everyone's just waiting because
because nobody wants to make the call
that's what this is it's a physical
cowardice of they didn't want to put
their own
lives on the line obviously even though
that's the job they signed up for
but there's also the moral cowardice of
not wanting to make the call not wanting
to be the one to say it's time to go in
okay you want to hide behind the order
someone gives you the order because
finally when the order was given and it
was clear like finally they did go in
and after it was far too late for a lot
of those kids
but that's i think much of the the
cowardice that was going on that day
hiding behind the order you want you
want to get the order from someone so
that if it goes wrong you can blame them
and that to me is even that's even
sicker
than the uh the physical cowardice part
of it as sick and revolting and pathetic
as that is
the fact that
all those men
so-called alleged men were outside that
classroom
worried for their physical safety but
also thinking to themselves well i if
this goes wrong i need to be able to
blame somebody i don't want to go in
myself
you know we need to hire up to order it
and uh so that they then we can blame
them if it doesn't go well
that's part of the calculation as
they're sitting outside the classroom
and kids are dying
is uh how do i protect my how do i
protect my own ass physically and also
just career advancement everything else
all right this is uh from the daily wire
it says on tuesday the supreme court of
the united states ruled that the
government cannot ban taxpayer-funded
tuition assistance for private education
from being used by citizens for private
religious education in the case carson
versus macon
uh scotus ruled six to three along
ideological lines at the state of
maine's tuition assistance program which
barred guardians from using the funds
for religious for private religious
education was unconstitutional as it
violated the first amendment supreme
court chief justice john roberts opined
um quote maine's non-sectarian
requirement for its otherwise generally
available tuition assistance payments
violates the free exercise clause of the
first amendment in short the prohibition
on status-based discrimination under the
free exercise clause is not a permission
to engage in use-based discrimination
this is the right decision
of course and uh the objections are
absurd
sotomayor said that this erodes the
separation of church and state
which it doesn't really but also the
separation of church and state was never
meant to be a legal principle the way
that we see it now today that was
something that thomas jefferson wrote in
a letter to the danbury baptist because
he was worried about the state's
influence on the church not the other
way around
and he also didn't write it
okay it wasn't was not written into the
constitution
um and besides
the other thing is that public schools
are already effectively religious
institutions
they are already institutions that teach
and preach and indoctrinate kids into
the uh religion of leftism as we've
talked about
now the left in criticizing this they've
once again revealed that they don't
understand their opposition
um and also they that they they see
everything in terms of racial and ethnic
identity that's just how they see
everything that's the lens through which
they view everything so they expect us
to view things the same way when we
don't in fact
like that's not when we encounter an
issue we don't immediately start
breaking it down along racial lines and
start thinking about well how is it
going to affect this group and that
group and everything we don't do that
but they do so um there's been a lot of
this kind of thing like this from
wajahat ali the daily beast he tweeted
private islamic schools and jewish
schools should open up all over maine
the state has to fund you now so take
advantage of it move your communities
there as well let's see what the supreme
court says
and i guess he i guess he thinks that
conservatives are going to say oh no we
didn't mean that
no we don't want any islamic schools or
jewish schools
no of course everybody on the right is
saying okay great
sounds good
yeah absolutely um absolutely that's
that's fantastic open up islamic schools
open up jewish schools open up all kinds
of private uh education
facilities
that sounds great and if you're a muslim
parent
and you say you want to send your kids
to an islamic school i think that's a
fantastic idea i think it's better than
sending a public school
and that of course is what all con
that's how all conservatives are
reacting to this tweet saying yeah okay
sounds good
um this is just the left revealing its
own bigotries
this is like when the lady on the view
who i think was joy behar said uh said
about gun control said well wait until
black people get guns then conservatives
will oppose it
and of course our response is number one
they have guns and number two that's
great
the more the merrier we want more people
to exercise their second amendment
rights fantastic
we have no problem with that
ali followed this up with this tweet he
says
do maine taxpayers have to fund a church
of satan school
i mean based on the supreme court ruling
the answer would have to be yes right
well as far as that goes
maine taxpayers already do fund
church of satan schools that's called
the public school system
so that's already happening
we already have
there are there are thousands of schools
in this country that are effectively run
by the church of satan and it's called
the public school system so that's
already happening we're aware of that
and um having more schools that are run
according to the doctrines of other
religions rather than satanism to me
sounds like a great idea i think we're
all on board with that okay i want to
move to this and uh first i want to read
you a little bit of a story from april
of this year and then we'll get to the
update this is from the washington
examiner in april of this year it says a
fundraiser for connecticut child
recovering from second and third degree
burns
has raised over 230 thousand dollars as
of wednesday night the money will be
used to help the family of six-year-old
dominique crancal
uh crankle i think probably how you
pronounce that find a new place to live
crankle was a hospitalized sunday after
another child covered a ball in gasoline
set it on fire and threw it at him
according to the family's gofundme page
kayla deegan whose crinkle sister said
quote
this kid downstairs has gotten away with
too much and has a history of bullying
the mother thinks he's innocent the
family thinks it's a joke even though
dominic can't talk because he's in a lot
of pain and all swollen he said to my
mom please don't take me back there
crankle is able to eat a few bites of
food past his extremely swollen lips but
he uh is expected to recover okay so the
story was that this child was attacked
by two bullies who they all live in the
same apartment complex i think and they
were outside
the child was attacked by by these
bullies who who lit a ball on fire
tennis ball and threw it at him
maliciously and this is the story the
family told and it's the story the
mother of this of the victim told
and um
they raised lots of money off the story
to buy a house
but then this from the daily wire this
is yesterday
says in april the family of a
six-year-old
dominic crenkel accused other
neighborhood children of a bullying
attack after crinkle suffered second and
third degree burns but newly released
surveillance footage casts doubt on the
family's allegation dominick kregel was
reportedly playing in the backyard at
his family's home in bridgeport
connecticut with neighborhood children
when the incident occurred
the children who were unattended were
reportedly lighting things on fire with
gasoline and crankle's mother and sister
claimed the six-year-old was set on fire
by bullies who threw a tennis ball at
him however those claims have come into
question after police said there was no
wrongdoing and footage of the incident
was released to the public and uh i saw
the footage on being circulated on
social media
the daily mail reports newly released
video appears to disprove a connecticut
mother's claim that her son was targeted
by bullies instead showing a seeming
accident as kids play dangerously with
fire so
you know you could see in the video
clearly
that they're just the kids they they
have uh these are kids ranging in age
from six to eight
and they somehow got their hands on
gasoline and a lighter
and they're just playing with it and
messing around and then one of the kids
gets set on fire and then one of the
other kids you can see in the video one
of the other kids that was that was
slandered as a bully
by the other child's mother he actually
tries to he uses his own bare hands to
try to put the fire out and we can
assume he's burned and himself in the
process tries to help the the boy by
putting the fire out
and probably saves him from suffering
much worse damage
now i actually saw this story when it
first happened and uh i didn't talk
about it on my show because i didn't
believe it
and the reason i didn't believe it
the version where the bully was was you
know the kid was attacked by bullies who
lit a ball on fire and threw it at him
the reason i didn't believe that is for
one thing
they're raising money for a new house
off of the story and i wish people would
just get this through their heads okay
and i really i i'm beseeching you for
your own sake
nobody can afford this economy to be
wasting money on scam gofundmes
okay
and um every gofundme you see you should
be skeptical of doesn't mean never
donate to any of them but be skeptical
of them because it's unless you know the
person personally there should be
immediate skepticism
unless you know the person or it's a
gofundme for aoc is a boiler those are
the two scenarios where you can give
without worrying about it outside of
that be skeptical
and if there was some sort of incident
that happened
and the victim or the the family of the
victim the first thing they do is set up
a gofundme
and they're going to use the money in a
way that doesn't even have anything
really to do with the incident now it's
one thing if they said we're going to
raise the money because he has terrible
burns we need to get in plastic surgery
uh to take care of the burn the scars
they don't even say they said we we want
the money to go buy a new house
and people are giving to that gofundme
like you didn't see talk about red flags
you didn't see them there
and also
right occam's razor here like go with
the simpler explanation
and when you see a story like this
there's a much simpler and more
believable explanation for how a
six-year-old boy got burned by fire and
gasoline
and that is that they were messing
around with fire and then he got burned
in the process
that's um that's a believable and simple
explanation
because because here's the thing if you
um are are leaving
young boys aged six to eight unattended
with gasoline and a lighter
somebody is getting set on fire that's a
100
it's not even a possibility it's a 100
certainty that's going to happen
so it's pretty obvious this mother was
uh not paying attention to her own son
and that's how they somehow got their
hands on gasoline and a lighter and now
she's trying to shift the blame and in
the process you know like defaming these
uh these poor kids and this other family
who are not the villains in this is just
a terrible accident
um okay one other thing before we get to
the comment section i wanted to read
this from mashable it says earlier this
week a twitter user shared pictures of
what she thought looked like cameras
disguised as fire sprinklers scattered
throughout her airbnb in philadelphia
this prompted other users to begin
sharing their air and b bar airbnb
horror stories on twitter while an
investigation conducted by the
philadelphia police concluded that there
were no hidden cameras in the airbnb the
social media damage had already been
done and so that's why on twitter there
were trending for a while airbnb people
were sharing their horror stories of
being in airbnbs
um
and uh some of the tweets someone says
lol airbnb hosts are like i need you to
take your shoes off in the house take
the garbage out turn the music down if
you want to live under this roof you got
to follow my rules it's like you're
living at your parents house at 19 as a
service someone else says we just
abandoned an airbnb in new york city
claimed to have ac in a double bed also
had lovely stains on the sheets and
couch
and there was a
apparently a turd that was i don't know
if this was was this
amber heard's house that he was staying
at
but there was there was fecal matter in
the house apparently a lot of other
horror stories like this i'm just
reading this to get to the point that i
want to make
which is um
why are you all staying at airbnbs
there are limited circumstances where i
can understand it like if you're going
away on vacation you want to find a home
like a lakefront home or something
and maybe you use airbnb for that if you
need a long-term rental you're staying
somewhere for three months maybe use
airbnb for that but people use airbnb
when they're just visiting town for a
few days they use it when they're
traveling and that's what i don't get
you want to go stay in somebody's house
you want to stay in someone else's house
and pay for it staying in other people's
houses that's the worst thing
i don't like staying in my own families
if i'm visiting family i prefer to stay
in a hotel than stay in their house
because it's uncomfortable it's awkward
you know nothing is set up the way that
you would set it up uh you're in someone
else's house it's their rules it's their
everything they never have their kitchen
set up the right way every time i'm in
somebody else's kitchen i'm just
thinking to myself why would you put the
forks and knives here why would you put
the cups there not over there doesn't
make any sense the way things are laid
out
makes no sense to me
especially when you consider there's a
whole industry
that had previously been set up for the
purposes of providing accommodations to
travelers it's called the hotel industry
and hotels are great i love hotels i'm a
hotel enthusiast
some hotels aren't good but you know if
they're not going to be good based on
the brand based on the price so you know
what you're getting into ahead of time
and the hotels are specifically designed
for the purpose of staying in for a few
days when you're on the road
you know everything's going to be
if you can't find it you can call down
and there's there's a whole staff that's
there and their whole job is to just
wait on you hand and foot
there's a bar
someone will come and
make your bed every morning if you want
they'll bring fresh towels it's
fantastic
the only reason it's saying airbnb is
that it's cheaper but it's actually not
cheaper anymore a lot of times it's more
expensive
so stay in a hotel this message brought
to you by the hotel industry actually
i'm doing it for free because i'm that's
how generous i am well the sweet baby
gang has proven yet again that it's
financial loyalty knows no bounds the
virtue signal patch which was released
on monday sold out yesterday in fact we
uh well it's really we i invented it in
my head live on the air just uh you know
riffing
last week and then we put it on and then
we actually made it and then it sold out
right away so these things move fast on
that wall show in fact it almost sold
out as fast as the people who actually
engage in virtue signaling almost i
think we could do better though because
many of you may not have had the chance
to secure your patch and because i am
wildly generous we are going to be
restocking the patch to give you another
opportunity to seize the moral high
ground head over to my swag shack
dailywire.com shop to claim your virtual
signal patch and the indulgent sense of
self-satisfaction that comes with it
today
let's get now to the comment section
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
jonathan says hey matt an important
point you missed about megan rapinoe is
that she like many others have closed
the door on the generation behind them
after they had success
she didn't have to compete with boys
growing up and she's rich and famous
because of her success but she's closing
the door for other women in her position
because she's got hers it's similar to
comedians who made a living telling
provocative jokes and then telling young
comedians those same jokes are offensive
that's a good point that's exactly uh
what's happening here and you said she
didn't have to compete against males but
she did as we talked about yesterday she
did at least one time have to compete
against
boys who were
under the age of 15 and she lost but now
right she's uh this is this is what all
this is why i despise even more it's one
thing to have the gen z tick tock
generation leftists who are
just uh have been crazy from birth and
that's one thing but to have these older
the kind of old crusty over the hill
leftists who are who made it across
right like you say they made it to
success and now they're pulling up the
drawbridge behind them in this way
is uh that's even worse i agree with you
let's see
dennis says juneteenth does not have to
be racial animosity turned into a
holiday racial animosity is acting like
you're just as oppressed as your
ancestors and society never recognized
slavery as wrong a celebration of the
end of slavery is the polar opposite
uh i got a lot of comments like this
that oh juneteenth
it does doesn't have to be that it
doesn't have to be a this this leftist
thing and you're right it doesn't have
to be
there's no reason why it had to go in
this direction but it has i mean that's
doesn't have to be this but this is what
it is
um and this is
now you could go and talk about the
other versions of juneteenth that they
had in texas or wherever else but
this federally recognized
nationwide holiday
like this version of it that was
invented
a couple of years ago
um it exists for all the reasons we
talked about yesterday
for racial division
uh grievance mongering
white guilt and all of that that's why
that exists
and it's got nothing to do with
patriotism it's actually got nothing to
do with celebrating freedom
as great as it would be to have a
holiday like that but again we actually
do have a holiday like that and uh the
great thing is that it happens just a
few weeks after juneteenth july 4th
that's a time for celebrating freedom
it's not a coincidence by the way that
many of the um
most ardent advocates of juneteenth are
not big fans of july 4th
because freedom isn't really their back
it's not what they actually care about
the most
um
jesse says only matt could take a lovely
sentiment about the sharing of birthdays
and turn it around to benefit him with
with uh him being given more presence
matt is a truly a master of being alpha
male to even one up his son on who got
the baddest stitches and trauma trophy
matt you are a kid in an alpha male
adult body
uh i don't is that really alpha male
status to try to one-up as i did my
nine-year-old son after he got stitches
does that make me
does that make me alpha male or just
incredibly petty
i guess it's up to you
to decide
and
finally raptor jesus says i do love how
matt pronounced the commenter prince
prince vegeta's name it's vegeta
matt he's from dragon ball z
well raptor jesus did you expect me to
actually know that
you know how i am with pronunciations
and maybe i've never covered my stance
on anime but you could probably guess
what it is
so you can't be too surprised by that
but thanks for that information anyway
coming up next week we have our biggest
live event of the year backstage live at
the ryman there are only a few tickets
left so don't miss out on this
incredible event we want to make sure
there's a lot of sweet baby gang
representation there so uh make sure to
snatch those tickets up now what is
backstage live it's your favorite daily
wire host in person like you've never
seen them before you have to see it to
believe it just take a look at last
year's
[Music]
at the event ryman auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office yeah one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
backstage live happens right here in
nashville on june 29th get your tickets
now
so get your tickets today at
dailywire.com ryman but if you can't
join us in person be sure to tune in
live to the live stream by becoming a
daily wire member at dailywire.com walsh
not only will you be able to see the
live stream but you'll get access to our
entire content library including what is
a woman tara on the prairie great shows
like this one and so much more use code
walsh for 25 off your new membership at
dailywire.com
walsh now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
now in fairness you have to understand
how difficult this is for the left
they're they're in a very tough spot you
know though of course they put
themselves in this spot they've decided
to go all in defending drag shows for
children given that this is an entirely
indefensible and abhorrent and utterly
shocking and degraded practice there
really aren't any good arguments
available to them they could therefore
abandon their child drag advocacy and
reclaim whatever sliver of dignity they
might have had left they could throw up
their hands and say okay you know what
uh we may have gone a little too far
with this actually it is super weird and
disgusting to have cross-dressing
fetishes
performing for preschoolers
so never mind let's just forget about
this whole thing
they could do that but they won't
they never backtrack they never
apologize never admit that they're wrong
about anything their only option is to
go full speed ahead all the time and
that leaves them scrambling for ways to
justify the pedophilic combination of
drag queens and children
this week on social media they seem to
think that they've maybe stumbled upon a
talking point which might accomplish
this feat for them the problem is that
the argument they've settled on actually
undermines the premise that they seek to
defend
once again they've pulled the pin out of
the grenade and then they just dropped
it at their own feet
certainly not the first time this has
happened so in recent days mrs doubtfire
the 1993 robin williams comedy where he
pretends to be an old woman so that he
can nanny his children without his
estranged wife finding out and it's one
of those movies from the 90s that when
you describe it now it just sounds
really weird but that movie has been
trending on twitter and that is due to
tweets like this one from alleged
comedian whitney cummings
who wrote quote
these old weirdos worried about drag
queens and kids forgot that our favorite
movies as kids were tootsie mrs
doubtfire and the nutty professor
yes because the people who don't want
men to cross-dress in front of children
are weirdos we're the ones who are
weirdos
but this comparison to old comedies
involving men in drag has become popular
mocking concerns about the drag queen
child combination max kennerly tweeted i
was 11 when i saw mrs doubtfire it had a
lasting negative impact on me
specifically i couldn't comprehend how
they didn't realize this was cake icing
not facial cream had the whole world
gone mad my young mind was damaged
emily murnane another woman who pretends
to be a comedian tweeted in a similar
vein
it's true i watched mrs doubtfire as a
child and grew up to be morally depre a
morally depraved loser and i do not see
how this could be a coincidence
well she wasn't joking about being a
morally depraved loser at least a guy
named nate david grossman chimed in with
his own version of this hilarious joke
tweeting you think that's bad i was 13
when i saw will ferrell dress up as
janet reno on snl this led directly to
heroin
now there are many other examples of
this talking point but you get the idea
many of us grew up watching comedies
involving men in drag and we turned out
fine relatively so what's wrong with
children at drag shows
that's that's like the argument
well the first and most obvious response
is that to my memory
there is no scene in mrs doubtfire where
robin williams strips down to a thong
and twerks on the ground while children
throw money at him
maybe i go back and watch it again but
i'm pretty sure it didn't happen
that's precisely what happens though at
drag shows
you don't have to be the most perceptive
person in the world to notice a
difference here
namely the difference is that the point
of one is to be funny
well the point of the other is to be
sexual
there's a reason why these drag shows
are not at comedy clubs they're at gay
clubs
there's no neon sign in the background
that says chuckle hut or laugh factory
instead the neon sign says as was the
case in one of these drag shows for kids
it's not going to lick itself
the drag events are sexually charged by
their nature that's the point of them
that's why they exist
the audience at a drag show does not sit
there and point and laugh the whole time
they're not there to mock the drag queen
for how ridiculous he looks
and the children at the drag show are
not meant to come away with the idea
that it's absurd or silly or stupid for
men to dress like women quite the
opposite
and that brings us to the second and
most crucial point and this is where the
grenade goes off and blows to pieces the
people who tried to throw it uh against
us the point is this
mrs doubtfire
could not exist today as a film it
couldn't be made
and that's not because conservatives
would object it's the left that would
have a connection fit over it why
because the comedy in mrs doubtfire and
film similar to it entirely raw revolves
around the fundamental absurdity of
males dressing like females we're
supposed to laugh about it and at it
the cross-dressing man is essentially a
clown wearing a ridiculous outfit for
our amusement
indeed the comedy makes no sense there
is no comedy at all unless you recognize
the differences between men and women
and believe that somebody in one
category can never cross over to the
other
the laughs come from that basic
understanding
mrs doubtfire is funny because it's
absurd and it's absurd because a man is
wearing women's clothing and that's
absurd
but the left says that we have to take
cross-dressing men seriously
they say it's not comedy at all but a
deep expression of their inner being
what's more they say gender is fluid and
so there's nothing fundamentally absurd
about a biological male presenting
himself as a female
in modern america mrs doubtfire would be
condemned as a transphobic homophobic
gender exclusionary
reinforcing the gender binary and all
that
or else if something like it was made
today it wouldn't be a comedy but a
drama
it would be the inspiring story of a man
who identifies as an elderly woman and
struggles for to be accepted you know by
society and his own family
like if the exact movie of mrs doubtfire
had never existed
and then was made in 2022
the left would watch it and either they
would want to burn at the stake
everybody involved or they would think
that it's inspirational drama like they
would not see it as a comedy
unless i'm wrong
perhaps i should take these leftists at
their own word
they're saying that modern drag shows
and mrs doubtfire are the same that's
what they're saying
okay so
can i then point and laugh at drag
queens
can i say that they look ridiculous
can i teach my children that when they
see a man dressed like a woman it's
funny and silly and they should not take
it seriously they should laugh at it
now i have taught my children that
that's exactly what i've told them on
the few occasions when we've been out in
public and they have uh
unfortunately incidentally witnessed
something like this
i've told them that's silly that's
ridiculous that's all that is
and i'm going to tell my children that
whether i have permission from the left
or not but are they now endorsing that
approach
something tells me they're not not
intentionally anyway
they're just saying whatever they think
will be most effective in the moment
even if it contradicts everything else
they say in every other moment as usual
and for that reason they are today
cancelled and we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
today on the ben shapiro show the
federal reserve boosts interest rates by
75 basis points for the first time since
1994 even as retail sales unexpectedly
declined plus joe biden hosts an
lgbtq plus minus divided by sign
celebration at the white house while
announcing government action to trans
the kids that's today on the benchmark
show give it a listen